AND YOU TOUCHED ON NICK
SCHMALTZ, IT'S GOING TO TAKE
SOME TIME.
HE MISSED 19 GAMES IN FRONT.
COYOTES LOOK TOSBEHERE WITH THE
LONE GOAL FOR THE COYOT COYOTEST
BACK TO SET IT UP. FANCY, GOT T
THE PUCK THERE.
THAT'S THE PULL IT IN.
AND IT'S TAKEN THE BEAUTY OF ITS
TEED THAT ONE
UP.
AND BACK OF THE FLORIDA
GOAL.
AND THEY MAD CANNOT HAPPEN.
AFTER YOU ALLOW A GOAL AND
SO NOW DOWN 2-0, HAVE TO FINE A
WAY TO GET BACK IN THE GAME A
GOES WIDE.   RIPPER BY
KESSEL.
RIPS ONE DEEP.
GOAL BY SAM BENNETT GETTING IN
THE CORNER AND THAT'S WHAT YOU
NEED ON
PERIOD COMING TO AN S THE CONFI
HERE AND THEY WILL COURTESY OF
HAYTON.
HAYTON WASNETTING.
>> WELL, LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT PHIL
GOSTISBEHERE TOWARD THE NET, AR
NOBODY WANTS TO TAKE BENNETT.
PENN TO THE LI WIND YOU UP
AND ANOTHER
GOALS, HE GETS ALL OF THIS ONE
AND HE RIPS IT
CHYCHRUN.
SENDS
>> BACK IN READ,
REAL  FACE-OFF AS
YOU LOOK AT JAKOB CHYCHRUN
BACK TO THE LINE, BUT IT GETS
DEFLECTED
EMPTY NET.
ANDRE TOURIGNY ROLLING THE DICEN